taoufik jebali quelles seront les
conséquences pour donald trump cette
intrusion au capitole on a vu ces
opposants réclament et le 25e amendement
des états unis pour déclarer inapte un
président ils ont écrit une lettre à
mike pence
est ce que il reste qu'un jour je le
rappelle à donald trump pour pour
gouverner mais quelles conséquences pour
lui aujourd'hui à mon avis sur le plan
politique immédiat il n'y a pas de
conséquence je pense pas que le congrès
américain aura le temps et le courage de
destituer le président à quinze jours
évidemment de son départ donc sur ce
plan là je pense pas qu'il y ait qu il
ya vraiment un danger pour 30
encore une fois je parle de ces quinze
jours qui nous restent par rapport à son
départ est évidemment l'investiture de
deux barres étonne par contre à long
terme il peut y avoir des problèmes
pourtant pour tremper haut niveau sur le
plan juridique il a énormément de
problèmes à gérer
après la maison blanche des problèmes
d'ordre financier des problèmes d'ordre
juridique énormément de problèmes
et dans ce cas là je pense que et la lra
quelques mois extrêmement difficile mais
je pense que par rapport à la
destitution dont on parle aujourd'hui
les républicains vont certainement faire
obstruction à cette démarche parce que
les républicains il faut savoir que ils
étaient des soldats
obéissant pendant quatre ans a tramp ce
sera difficile aujourd'hui pour eux de
retourner leur veste et de s'attaquer
frontalement a tramp qui reste quand
même extrêmement populaire par rapport
au noyau dur des républicains donc je
comprends tout à fait le dilemme dont
ils se trouvent ces républicains s'ils
soutiennent trempe là il ya un problème
politique morale éthique qui va se poser
s'il s'attaque à trempe une perdent
certainement la base solide du parti de
république a donc quelque part ils sont
tout à fait dans une situation inédite
mais une situation extrêmement
compliquée pour eux donc je pense qu'ils
vont certainement né s'est passé ces
deux semaines qui restent pour entamer
une peut-être refondation du parti
républicain plus tard alors vous le
lisiez donald trump toujours très
populaire en tout cas pour son électorat
de base
les anciens présidents américains jimmy
carter barack obama l'ont accusé d'avoir
allumé la mèche on l'a vu donald trump
lui a tweeté à plusieurs reprises pour
appeler au calme
il a rappelé sa devise la loi et à
l'ordre la loi et l'ordre mais il n'a
pas été entendu il a été dépassé par ses
propres partisans cette fois peut-être
pas dépasser des certaine il a peut-être
inspiré ces événements quelque part
puisque il avait appelé lui même ses
partisans à venir à washington
manifester devant la capitainerie
sachant qu'il y avait un risque énorme
de débats de débordements donc quelque
part je ne pense pas qu'il soit vraiment
dépassé débordée par sa base
c'est au contraire ils envoient des
messages parfois clair parfois qu'au
départ fois moins clair mais en tout cas
il est en symbiose je dirais avec sa
base pendant ces événements là une femme
a été tuée hier soir au capitole
on ne sait pas on ne connaît pas encore
exactement l'origine des tirs
taoufik jebali cette violence et ce
droit est évidemment apporté des armes
aux états unis ça on veut ni mais les
choses selon vous cette image restera
dans l'histoire des états unis
cette image restera dans l'histoire des
états unis
c'est quelque part je suis désolé de le
dire presque c'est l'arroseur arrosé les
états unis avait fomenté parfois des
troubles en dehors des états unis
aujourd'hui on le voit chez eux
mais est on a vu aux états unis il y a
la violence c'est une pratique
extrêmement répondu la violence
politique peut être un peu moins mais on
a vu dans le michigan
des manifestants armés et lourdement
armés envahir évidemment le congrès du
michigan
donc quelque part c'est c'est pas long
c'est pas l'événement lui même c'est le
côté symbolique de l'événement qui
provoque et qui est intéressant c'est
les etats-unis ont toujours assurer une
passation de pouvoir dans le calme et
depuis george washington depuis le
xviiie siècle on a vu même shawn adams a
perdu les élections 18 ans il a laissé
sa place dans le calme thomson la
pression des suisses ont donc quelque
part c'est inédit mais surtout c'est pas
moi je ne suis pas tout à fait étonnés
de voir des morts et peut-être il y
aurait des morts plus tard parce que la
question de ces élections est de ces
résultats n'est pas encore terminée il
ya une frustration énorme
parmi la base d'urée là est le noyau dur
du tropisme donc on va certainement
connaître d évoluer évolution politique
intéressant donc en tout cas à voir et à
observer
cela dit il ya 400 millions d'armes
individuelles qui circulent aux états
unis ça rend le problème extrêmement
complexe en le problème ex
potentiellement disant dangereux cela
était confirmé le chef de la police de
washington l'a bien confirmé
c'est un policier qui a tiré donc sur
cette dame qui était dans la police du
capitole donc des scènes qui ont été par
ailleurs minimisé relativiser en tout
cas par plusieurs médias plus ce plutôt
conservateur qui disait que finalement
cette intrusion n'était pas si grave que
cela
en accusant l'ultra gauche en avoir
infiltré le mouvement est ce que c'est
un sentiment qui est partagée dans le
pays
non je ne pense pas de toute façon
l'infiltration de l'ultra gauche
ça m'étonnerait vraiment dans ces
conditions là ils n'ont aucun intérêt
puis c'est plutôt la base c'est plutôt
les partisans purs et durs du tropisme
qui étaient là donc c'est mais c'est
c'est politiquement ça rapporte à trempe
ça rapporte à ses partisans d'accuser
toujours l'extrême gauche qui est
certainement tout à fait rejeter dans
l'esprit dans l'imaginaire dans la
sphère politique américaine donc c'est
une accusation qui ne va pas passer à
mon avis puisque pratiquement la police
le sait les hommes politiques américains
le savent c'est plutôt trempe qui était
derrière ces événements de façon directe
ou indirecte par rapport à ces messages
toujours codé toujours sur le fil du
rasoir c'est ceni wind et n'ont ni
violence mais l'ordre sait on l'a vu
avec la question de sur la question
raciale était valide elle 30 a néanmoins
appelé hier soir justement quand les
choses sont venues mais à ses partisans
à rentrer chez eux sauf que ces deux
vidéos diffusées sur twitter a été
censurée comment comment est ce
compliqué ça il ya deux problèmes je
crois tout d'abord dans le message lui
même quand on le voit il appelle ses
partisans à rentrer mais en même temps
il insiste sur la fraude électorale donc
c'est déjà un problème
l'autre problème qui me paraît
impensable aussi c'est d'interdire à
quelqu'un aux états unis de parler et en
l'occurrence le président des états unis
c'est une censure inhabituel aussi aux
états unis le premier amendement de la
constitution qui remonte à 10 791
stipule bien
dans l'amendement numéro 1 déjà que le
congrès américain ont le système
politique en général le pouvoir n'a pas
le droit de censurer et la censure est
interdite
on le voit aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui sont sûr mais on sent
sur quelqu'un on sent sur le président
des états unis
ça c'est une sur le plan politique et
biologique
c'est plutôt une aberration même si on
peut ne pas être d'accord avec trempe
mais de là à l'interdire de parler à
l'interdire de s'exprimer c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement grave
taoufik jebali qu'est ce que ça dit
justement du rapport de donald trump
avec les géants du net un twitter
facebook notamment
c'est trempe avait utilisé twitter en
particulier et c'est un grand client de
twitter c'est certainement le client le
plus populaire le plus important pour
twitter par contre il avait toujours par
rapport à la question des médias
il avait toujours accusé les médias que
ce soit les réseaux sociaux que ce soit
les médias classiques de fakes news de
fomenter des informations contre lui ou
contre les nids biologie conservatrice
américaine et ainsi de suite donc il est
plus dans le dans le sillage de cette
idée comme quoi il y avait un complot
contre lui contre ses partisans et et
dans ce cas là le rapport dès le premier
jour et même avant des élections de 2016
il y avait un rapport extrêmement
tendues avec les médias
et ça continue et on l'a vu dans des
accrochages extrêmement métier
médiatisée avec les journalistes et au
delà de ces journalistes là il ya les
barons de des réseaux sociaux qui ont
pris une place prépondérante à l'échelle
des états unis mais à l'échelle mondiale
et on a vu que trempe bien qu'il soit
capable d'utiliser ces réseaux de façon
tout à fait exceptionnelle extrêmement
performante
il avait quand même toujours cette idée
de critiquer les médias et
de montrer toujours de se montrer
toujours de se mettre toujours dans la
peau de la victime plutôt de quelqu'un
qui manipulent au pays utilisent les
médias pour ses propres intérêts taoufik
divali une question se pose ce matin
comment est-ce que des partisans de
donald trump ont pu pénétrer dans
l'enceinte du capital un millier de deux
forces de la garde nationale 1 ont dû
être envoyés sur place des forces
spéciales également ont dû intervenir
comment c'est possible cette intrusion
le périmètre de sécurité apparemment n'a
rien vu venir
en fait on lisait déjà depuis quelques
semaines des choses sur cette journée on
avait prévu il y avait des gens qui
avaient prévu tout cela on pense même
que apple avait arrêté le gps qui menait
vers washington c'est pour vous dire que
c'était extrêmement c'était prévu par
contre maintenant
connaissant un petit peu le cas que tout
redevienne le congrès américain de
l'extérieur mais j'ai eu aussi
l'occasion rentrée c'est il y a une
sécurité extrêmement impressionnante et
encore ces dernières années la la la la
la sécurité les mesures de sécurité ont
été renforcées
maintenant comment se fait-il que avec
quelques centaines de personnes en
arrivent à pénétrer facilement rentrer
facilement dans ce bâtiment immense et
imposant est impressionnant c'est que il
va falloir peut-être faire une enquête
pour voir s'il n'y avait pas vraiment
soit de l'incompétence de la part des
chefs de la police soit une complicité
quelconque mais évidemment ça c'est
vraiment pas moi personnellement je suis
un peu surpris il a fallu bien entendu
le renfort de la garde nationale de la
virginie et du maire juste à côté parce
que comme washington n'est pas un état
ils n'ont pas une garde nationale donc à
washington il y avait il ya la police il
ya le maire de washington il n'y a pas
de gouverneur à washington ce qui fait
que la sécurité à washington
reste un petit peu ambigu même si on ne
peut pas dire qu'il y a une sécurité
laxistes surtout que c'est le centre
quand même névralgique du pouvoir aux
états unis donc là c'est vraiment tout
le monde est surpris et encore une fois
qu'en descendant droit ça me paraît
impensable alors les réactions à travers
le monde se sont multipliées après la
diffusion de ces images donc du capitole
envahi je vous propose de regarder et
puis on réagit ensuite le secrétaire
général est attristé par les événements
survenus mercredi au capitole américain
à washington
dans de telles circonstances il est
important que les dirigeants politiques
fassent comprendre à leurs partisans
la nécessité de s'abstenir de recourir à
la violence ainsi que de respecter les
processus démocratiques et l'état de
droit
scène honteuse au congrès américain les
etats unis sont les défenseurs de la
démocratie dans le monde entier et il
est désormais vital que le transfert de
pouvoir se fasse de manière pacifique et
ordonnée
trump et ses partisans devraient enfin
accepté la décision des électeurs
américains et cesser de piétiner la
démocratie quand dans une des plus
vieilles démocraties du monde
des partisans d'un président sortant
remettent en cause par les armes
les résultats légitimes d'une élection
c'est une idée universelle celle d'un
homme une voix qui est battue en brèche
je suis avec beaucoup d'inquiétude ce
qui se passe à washington
la violence est incompatible avec
l'exercice des droits politiques et des
libertés démocratiques
j'ai confiance dans la solidité et la
force des institutions des états unis je
crois en la force des institutions et de
la démocratie américaine
la transition pacifique du pouvoir est
essentiel joe biden a remporté
l'élection
je me réjouis de travailler avec lui en
tant que prochain président des états
unis scène très angoissante au congrès
américain nous condamnons ces actes de
violence et attendons avec impatience un
transfert pacifique du gouvernement à
l'administration nouvellement élu dans
la grande tradition démocratique
américaine scènes choquantes à
washington dc le résultat de cette
élection démocratique doit être
respectée scènes choquantes et
profondément triste à washington dc
nous devons clairement dire ce qui s'est
passé une attaque délibérée contre la
démocratie par un président en exercice
et ses partisans qui tentent de
renverser une élection libre et
équitable
le monde entier regarde nous espérons
que le calme reviendra
taoufik jebali on a vu ces réactions
indignées de la communauté d'une partie
en tout cas de la communauté
internationale c'est du pain bénit
puisque donald trump finalement n'était
pas forcément un allié facile n'était
pas un ami il facile au contraire mais
moi ce qui ce qui m'attire dont c'est ce
qui m'intéresse dans ses réactions
c'est en pensant que six trains avaient
gagné les élections évidemment on peut
penser que ces événements n'auraient
jamais eu lieu
mais le discours de ses leaders mondiaux
n'aurait compris était différent c'est
que au niveau mondial certainement les
relations avec 30 étaient difficiles
mais il y avait aussi je dirais pas de
la lâcheté mais il y avait du real
politique qui faisait en sorte qu' il
n'y avait pas une opposition frontale
claire explicite 1,30 et on a laissé
faire pendant quatre ans sans
pratiquement réagir sur pas mal de
questions et aujourd'hui on voit le
résultat
donc ces réactions là évidemment il faut
les mettre dans le contexte dans le
contexte de ces quatre années qui
viennent de s'écouler à savoir que la
relation était méprisant vis-à-vis des
grands chefs d'état de ce monde
je pense à merkel je pense à bien
d'autres et aujourd'hui évidemment à
tous beaucoup de gens beaucoup de ces
chefs d'état en particulier européens
les européens de l'ouest et même de
l'est aussi sens soulagé de le voir
partir
en tout cas le processus démocratique et
bien se poursuit on l'aurait presque
oublié les démocrates ont appris leurs
deux victoires dans les sénatoriales en
géorgie en quoi c'est un événement
majeur pour moi personnellement je pense
que c'est un événement encore plus
intéressant que ces actes de violence à
la capitale
parce que ça va définir l'orientation
politique des états unis pendant quatre
ans quand je dis les états unis c'est la
plus grande puissance mondiale donc ce
qui affecte les états unis affecte le
monde
donc ces quatre années aurait été
certainement serait certainement
différent différente si jamais les deux
démocrates avaient perdu en géorgie donc
là les républicains en cinquante
sénateurs déjà il a fallu une élection
favorable aux républicains en géorgie
pour que le congrès bascule clairement
dans le camp républicain
ce n'était pas le cas et je dois dire
c'était une surprise certainement une
excellente surprise pour les démocrates
qui avait 48 sénateurs et aujourd'hui il
se trouve majoritaire puisque en cas de
blocage c'est le vice président des
états unis et en l'occurrence qui est
présidente du sénat qui prendrait la
décision qui tranchera merci c'est un
grand événement fait on va bien sûr
continuer d'en parler taoufik jebali
avec vous merci en tout cas d'avoir
répondu dans cette première partie de la
matinale